blm is an explicitly marxist
organization
huge numbers of leftist professors who
are forming the minds of the next
generation of americans
are openly marxists and this is why by
the way so blm that's what's going on in
the streets right now that is the the
terrorist wing of the democratic party
blm is openly defending the cuban regime
blm sent out a statement quote
black i'm now truncated it was a very
very long statement but it wasn't as
funny as trump so i'll just just read
the highlights
black lives matter condemns the us
federal government's inhumane treatment
of cubans
pause right there the cubans living in
the united states
seem to be thriving you know they've got
i don't know if you've been to miami
recently they're living their best life
okay
they're doing a lot better than the
cubans are doing in cuba
where the cuban government actually is
oppressing them
blm urges the united states to
immediately lift the economic embargo
the people of cuba are being punished by
the u.s government because the country
has maintained its commitment to
sovereignty
and self-determination u.s leaders have
tried to crush this revolution for
decades right this
the the communist regime in cuba which
is now 60 years old is still called the
revolution
this is why the communist leaders like
fidel castro still wear military
fatigues
because they're they're obviously just
the dictatorship the corrupt
the corrupt government there but they
have to pretend that they're still
revolutionaries
because the revolution is always
perpetual on the left now we look to
president biden when the embargo
something barack obama called for in
2016.
this embargoes a blatant violation of
human rights and it must come to an end
the cuban protesters don't agree with
blm the cuban protesters wave
as their chief symbol of protest
the american flag they sew it onto their
blue jeans they put american flag
stickers onto their bicycles
i saw it myself that is the protest
symbol
in cuba in the united states
leftists chill for the communist regime
in cuba
and they burn the american flag and they
disrespect the american flag not just
the fringe radicals not just the blm
terrorists in the streets
but professional football players
elected
democrats all the way up they disrespect
the american flag that's the difference
hold up
i'm glad you liked that video you can
get the whole episode it's called the
real coup you can get it here on youtube
if you ring the bell subscribe
and you can get it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher
myspace xanga live journal aol instant
messenger hotmail
anywhere get it get it anywhere that's
the audio podcast you can also get my
book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you to everyone who made it a
number one national bestseller
see you next time
[Music]
you